ahora de nuevo bueno tenemos aquí este
rectángulo que se nos dice que la
longitud del segmento ab es 1 y también
nos dice que el segmento b y el segmento
b del tri se k el ángulo a abc entonces
bbv triste que en el ángulo abc y bueno
criticar significa dividir este ángulo
en tres en tres ángulos iguales lo cual
quiere decir que este ángulo de aquí es
igual a este ángulo y también es igual a
este ángulo y bueno quieren que
averigüemos cuál es el perímetro del
triángulo b de este triángulo que se
forma en medio en este rectángulo hay
que averiguar eso y bueno tal vez tú
digas cuánto mide este rectángulo como
yo inicio resolver este problema si
solamente me están dando la información
de este lado pero nos están dando
bastante información porque bueno ya
sabemos que es un rectángulo tiene
cuatro lados cuatro ángulos los lados de
hecho son paralelos unos a otros y los
cuatro ángulos son todos rectos así que
suficiente información para saber que en
definitiva esto es un rectángulo
ahora sabemos que los lados opuestos de
un rectángulo tienen la misma longitud
si este lado mide 1 también este lado
mide 1 y bueno también sabemos que este
es un ángulo que está triste cado y
sabemos cuánto mide porque es un ángulo
recto cierto así que si lo dividimos en
tres partes iguales nos dice que este
ángulo cada uno mide 30 éste mide 30
éste mide 30 y también éste mide 30
después podemos ver que estamos
trabajando con triángulos de 30 60 90
este mide 30 grados después 90 grados y
por lo tanto este debe valer 60 grados
cierto porque bueno suman 180 los
ángulos internos de un triángulo también
aquí tenemos 30 y después 90 por lo
tanto éste debe valer 60 grados también
así que tenemos triángulo 30 60 y 90
triángulo de 30 60 y 90 también acá y
podemos averiguar las medidas de este
triángulo aunque bueno no va a ser un
triángulo rectángulo pero con lo que
sabemos de triángulos de 30 60 90 si
sabemos cuánto mide un lado podemos
averiguar cuánto mide otro cierto así
que por ejemplo aquí tenemos que el lado
más corto
el opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados bueno
si este lado mide 1 entonces el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados mide raíz
de 3 x ese lado así que simplemente es
raíz de 3 y eso es muy útil porque ahora
sabemos cuánto mide toda la base del
rectángulo ahora usemos nuestros
conocimientos de triángulos de 30 60 90
y si te parece misterioso el resultado
que acabo de mencionar es olimpista solo
otro vídeo así que sabemos que los
triángulos de 30 60 y 90 sus lados están
a razón de 1 raíz de 3 y 2 así que si
este lado vale 1 entonces este lado mide
raíz de 3 por 1 y la hipotenusa valdrá 2
por la longitud así que la hipotenusa
tiene longitud de 2 por la amm esta
estela aunque esta longitud de aquí de
este lado así que 2 por 1 es 2 y bueno
quiero muy interesante porque podríamos
hacer lo mismo o algo similar con con
este triángulo de acá o este lado de acá
aquí el 1 es el lado opuesto al ángulo
de 60 grados no al de no al ángulo de 30
grados así que bueno una vez más si
multiplicamos este lado
por raíz de 3 obtenemos este lado así
que recuerda que este 1 corresponde al
lado opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados por
lo tanto deben debe medir 1 sobre raíz
de 3 ajá así que lo pongo aquí esto es 1
sobre raíz de 3 y la manera como yo
obtuve esto bueno es que si yo
multiplico 1 sobre raíz de 3 por raíz de
3 obtengo 1 así es como yo lo obtengo
obtengo la medida de este lado opuesto
al ángulo de 60 grados o si tomo el lado
opuesto al ángulo de 60 grados y lo
divido por raíz de 3 obtengo la medida
del lado más corto entonces si yo
empiezo con el lado que corresponde al
ángulo de 60 grados y lo divido por raíz
de 3 obtengo 1 sobre raíz de 3 ahora
cuánto vale la hipotenusa siempre va a
medir el doble de longitud del lado
opuesto al ángulo de 30 grados así que
en este caso este es el lado opuesto al
ángulo de 30 grados y la hipotenusa vale
el doble así que vale 2 sobre raíz de 3
y bueno hasta aquí vamos bien debemos
encontrar el perímetro de este triángulo
de en medio ya sabemos que un lado mide
ya sabemos que otro lado mi dedo sobre
raíz de 3 ahora solo queda averiguar
cuánto vale ed y eso lo podemos hacer
porque bueno ade es igual a veces dado
que este es un rectángulo así que a demi
de raíz de 3 porque b se mide raíz de 3
y si a demi de raíz de 3 ya mide 1 sobre
raíz de 3 entonces esta longitud de aquí
es de raíz de tres menos 1 sobre raíz de
3 cierto así que esta longitud menos
esta longitud y ahora encontrar el
perímetro sale muy directo porque
simplemente vamos a sumar estas
longitudes así que bueno hagámoslo
entonces el perímetro del triángulo el
perímetro del triángulo bf es igual esto
es igual a 2 lo escribo por acá es 2
sobre raíz de 3 + raíz de tres menos 1
sobre raíz de tres más dos
y bueno hasta aquí ya sólo sólo queda
simplificar puedes sacar la calculadora
si gustas y listo pero bueno veamos
vamos a ver esto tenemos entonces 2
sobre raíz de tres menos 1 sobre raíz de
3 es simplemente uno sobre raíz de 3
así quedó sobre raíz de 3 - unos reales
de 3-1 sobre raíz de 3 luego más raíz de
tres más raíz de tres más dos y puedo
racionalizar esto si multiplicó el
numerador y denominador por raíz de 3
eso me da a raíz de tres sobre tres más
raíz de tres lo cual puedo escribir como
3 raíz de 3 sobre 3 a ham 3 raíz de 3
sobre 3 y simplemente multiplicó por 3
sobre tres más dos ahora esto nos da una
raíz de tres más tres raíz de tres todo
sobre tres entonces nos va a dar 4 raíz
de tres sobre tres más dos entonces 4
raíz de tres sobre tres más dos
y ahí lo tenemos este es el resultado es
el perímetro del triángulo bd justo como
lo estábamos buscando así que es este
perímetro perímetro que encontramos es
el perímetro de este triángulo de en
medio nos vemos